the most annoying video on the internet
we reacted to it and it was absolute
torture
so we thought hey let's do that again
why not let's do it again
let's do it again that was epic i've
never seen
so many people unanimously hate a
group of people last one was adults
decide who gets a thousand this one is
millennials oh boy do you think
millennials will do better than adults
well i feel like millennials will
probably hate themselves more than
people will hate them i mean just look
at this shot right here everyone looks
like they're so happy to be here and
i'm just depressed other minds am i a
millennial
yeah yeah you're a millennial okay so i
get to put my main foot in there yeah
these are our people right here let's go
yeah i relate to this group i can tell
for sure
all right without further ado let's
check it out sunny
destiny oh my gosh tracy
oh my gosh last one
oh i can't wait to see who they're gonna
vote out that was so shocking
oh my god oh my gosh oh my gosh
what kind of t-shirt was i was so
[Laughter]
there's no way they can be more annoying
though that's just impossible
what are you guys here to do win some
money play money man
make friends make friends make friends
too many
sure make friends also
vote for me
[Laughter]
we see through you my first impression
here aside from of the one girl is like
everyone's trying to dress so plain
and like boring but also be like unique
in some way at the same time it's
ken who are you who the hell are you to
judge someone's dressing
huh i mean you got that blue t-shirt on
still no
i mean no i got my the shirt that mary
picked out for me it's a button up
uh with bats on it it's really cool all
right
all right i was wrong then it fits me
makes my make my guns look alright
anyone with a bat shirt that serves my
hun my
thousand what do you mean the game is
thousand to one how's this work you guys
one person will get a thousand dollars
or
no one gets anything can you choose to
like divide it up
nope oh you can't we can after i'm glad
that they addressed
it at least finally we have the answer
can they just split the money
that's like nope and the one goes like
we can do it after they won't know
yeah exactly that's the ultimate way to
doing this
let's just have the opinion that makes
it look good on the internet and then
we'll just split the money it doesn't
matter
that's the way to win this people and
those three people have to unanimously
decide
who leaves with a thousand dollars if
they can't make the decision nobody gets
the money
once you're voted off you sit on this
sad couch
it's a nice one yeah that couch looks
more comfortable that made no sense
i'm scared someone's gonna say like i'm
a bad person i'm scared of that too
honestly
welcome to the internet [ __ ]
worry about people think of you you got
to get over that you're here to win a
thousand dollars
yeah but i've what i've learned from the
last video is if you just say you're a
good person then you're a good person
right
well yeah do you remember that girl said
that last video she was like i am a good
person
and i need new tires no one that is a
good person says they're a good partner
you have to tell people you're a good
person you don't tell people you're a
good person
i can't believe we didn't notice that i
was so annoyed when everyone's like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with her
i'm a very good person okay i just i'm
i'm the best person you're the best well
i
am even i'm the greatest no you know
what yeah yes you are ken you're oh
you are the amazing also the most you
know humble and modest also
you know so uh you're supposed to know
we're supposed oh yeah
but you're so good yeah you deserve the
money
you deserve i'll take the money thank
you
i was gonna switch you
no one went for that i like that yeah i
can't appreciate how they're all
they're all worried about what other
people will think of them they seem very
self-conscious yeah look how timid and
like oh
that's probably what i would be as well
cut through by the end of this there's
no
i mean it is the cut recently one of my
dogs had to go through surgery
to get two tumors removed my apartment
for the summer
and i don't think a lot of people are
going to want to sublet it so
i'm just like oh i got to figure that
out it's so
big i got i have this thing that i don't
know how it's gonna go
so thousand dollars i would like some
money you know
me at least there's not that one obvious
person that has
like a really expensive clothing so
you're always right about downloading
her
left ear and in the case that she loses
hearing in her right ear i won't be able
to communicate with her i want to use
the money
specifically to pay for classes to take
american sign language courses
and i like have just enough scholarships
for school but like i need extra classes
do you know if there's any other ways
you could like i don't know
find uh a way to learn sign language or
like find somebody like in
the community it's probably easier to
learn sign language with an actual
teacher right yeah yeah probably so but
i like how they're doing the same thing
they've done in previous videos like in
the last year they were like
very aggressive but she's like so do you
think you could like i don't know
it's weird though they should just like
hear everyone out
and stop trying to validate each other
that's the thing that's so annoying with
these i feel like we're doing it as a
joke
as a joke obviously i don't know anybody
who knows sign language this like sounds
like fluff but because i'm involved a
lot of student leadership in my school
i like literally don't have the time to
work because i want to support like
minorities and like students of color at
my school and i prioritize that over
working okay so hang on like
he doesn't have time to work but he has
time to take a whole other class
[ __ ]
all right yeah no no say it's safe ken
say it i mean maybe the class isn't that
long you know maybe he's already there
at school you know
oh [ __ ]
i gotta say though like the whole
argument i don't have time
bro show me your phone right now what's
your screen time bro
huh what do you got instagram one hour
here yeah you learn it yeah oh okay
oh i see you 100 that's what they should
do
to go get help for like mental health
reasons and the treatment for it
is twenty four thousand dollars
basically we're at like a point where
the [ __ ] twenty four thousand dollars
for mental health
did you say did i hear that right yeah
that would give me mental health issues
just there
that would give me health issues what
the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] yeah my anxiety
just went through the room here and then
24 is that supposed to help anyone
congratulations we solved all your
health issues you are now in debt
and you are now in crippling debt for
the rest of you america thank you
[Laughter]
i would give it to the nonprofit
organization it's called jfs very local
they're the ones who brought me here to
america for my rack
so i would give them money back like
whoop jay
okay i don't know what it is it's been
four minutes 50 seconds i'm sorry to
interrupt you but
okay don't table it we'll get better
i'm here because my mom i owe her like
for tuition okay i was really sorry no
no go ahead i just feel like
a thousand dollars yeah it is a lot of
money
but it won't really get you that far
what the [ __ ]
what the girl said that she needed 24
000.
that's the same art you could why didn't
you pull that argument to that then
why don't you pull that argument out
first if it's so little money then why
do you need it huh
if it's not gonna get you that far why
do you want it
like that much it will barely help you
at all he said he owed 600 that would
that's it's got 400 surplus that's
amazing yeah
this summer i'm volunteering as a camp
counselor it's
for children 6 to 18 whose parents have
experienced cancer
you know part of being a camp counselor
is that we like raise at least 500
is it yours that sounds nice yeah i'll
give that guy sure
to like as a counselor to bring these
kids it's not like
if we don't fundraise the money then i
have to like pay out of pocket but there
is an expectation that as a counselor i
fundraise at least one
camper who do you feel like should be
voted off first
who do you think ken the the
pink hair girl on the bottom right she's
already getting my nerves get her out of
here
i don't want to hear it like she she's
got her short shirt on her
short pants on nothing fits her get her
out of here yeah go buy some pants
a summer camp i'm not sure if that's
like too comparable to like the
guarantees that other people could use
it for so like medical insurance for
like a dog
how do i respond to that but it was
don't vote out him please what was wrong
with that
he was the only one that wasn't a
counselor for traumatized children whose
parents have gone through a hard time i
don't think that you know equates to
you know me wanting to take sign
language class all right just
if the whole group says like that's not
enough of a good enough reason then like
i'm not going to fight anyone over okay
yeah good i wouldn't fight either
good god they always find it to make so
annoying i don't know what it is with
it's like they try to hide their
selfishness with like all these
like we got said fluff it's just like
blah blah blah blah blah blah just say
you want the money just be honest about
it i have to like pick apart what other
people said so maybe people forget what
my reason was is that how you guys want
to do it yeah
let's write it yeah nobody wants to
offend anyone and you know what people
can be more honest when let's do
that's true yeah yeah yes the internet
no one wants to offend anybody until
they're in the comments section and they
can write it
i never had a bad interaction face to
face
yeah yeah because they know i would kick
their [ __ ] ass
if you ever say anything to me yeah
you're so tough
i yelled at a guy from my car the other
day i was felt real good
why are you parked in the middle of the
road i was like yeah but did you
get to a stop lightning like he's like
walking after you're like oh god what do
i do
[ __ ] is he following me is he following
me oh god
call the cops
do i just go over there yeah [ __ ] you
and your charity aaron how dare you
how do you try how dare you think about
kids that have been traumatized
idiot what were you thinking seriously
they polish
every time every time every time
yeah hug it out
so aaron's in a fun seat like you don't
have the pressure of
getting voted so ask them who voted for
you i don't care
i imagine that like everybody believes
that their own reason was good enough so
that's fine who do you guys think is
next to get voted off
i feel like it's me do you think the
trick is going to go it works the third
time
every time they say it's going to be me
they everyone's like oh
now
every time they done it i'm so curious
so we got to do it again who voted for
me
i didn't let's just say we the point of
this sign was that you wouldn't know
you can't just pull
oh i did that with a board game once
it's so [ __ ] funny
it was a game where you're supposed to
make something like really sassy about
each other
and we were all supposed to write it
down so it was anonymous and then i had
a banger it was so good like
you could tell they hurt their soul this
thing that i wrote but it was funny
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i'd rather not know who voted for me
just cause like
i don't know i don't want to have any
hard feelings against like anyone so
like
don't we should all have our own charity
and then maybe pick the one that you
know we all think
we don't have to put it towards mine i
feel like we should
is that girl's face when he said that
she was like what ah
i gotta see it maybe pick the one that
you know we all feel strongly
[Laughter]
how would everyone have a charity ready
that is a weird car to pull
this part like you're the only one left
with a charity everyone's just gonna
come up with one
take the idea of just like helping other
people away so like
wait no listen
[Laughter]
just give the money straight to me all
right
there's the honest person in the group
right there yeah yeah yeah you
got it i mean i respect that at least
that's the thing
yeah dude if we're not using this money
for for like global development we're
not using it for sociology we're not
donating it to anybody we're using it
for ourselves
what are we going to use it for i love
helping people both right now
let's kind of forgot the colors right
here what the [ __ ] yeah that's really
stuck out there
like the two highest priority to me is
either aliyah
cause a she like genuinely has the
highest need
and then b i see muhammad because i feel
like he's giving it to a good cause so
that's who i would put
at my top two i'm gonna i'm gonna use
self selfish here
the idea of not of like not being able
to communicate with my mom because i
like don't know the only way that i
could
is like terrifying sunny
destiny oh my gosh
one vote oh my gosh nobody's voted for
me this time because i did the thing
it's a good strat you you got to pull it
in the in the last round
you use it too early in the game sonny
[Applause]
sonny was my favorite just because he
was clear and honest
at least i'm chilling i'll figure it out
i guess it's a good fight
i know somebody voted for me and i mean
like it was me
it was you yeah okay oh oh
you're good because uh you're out
and then the immediate question that
follows after why tell me exactly why
what do you like
about me what is wrong with you why do
you not like me
nobody seems mad though but like as i
said before like we're still walking out
like with the same that we came in with
it's weird how millennials are less
toxic than [ __ ] adults
i don't know how they found that group
from last video i'm still in shock by it
this is unbelievable these are a lot
they're a lot more mature
we just like don't remember what it was
oh i live in an apartment that's kind of
expensive which is why i'm trying to
bounce
and like subletting it is kind of hard
because like a lot of people don't want
to sublet it for the summer
so like it would help for that is that
better than charity i don't think no
i think everybody's not how
i don't know i feel like i trust destiny
so much yeah i trust you
that's true yeah we shall let destiny
choose our destiny
oh my god she's about to go into shock
they're like we don't want to do this so
yeah do it yay
literally have the same thing this whole
video now i have and everyone wants me
to do everything
why does everybody trust me all of a
sudden because you have a badass name
for destiny
okay what if we all like close our eyes
or like we all go behind
you and then you like point to one of us
so you don't have to say it out loud
and then the persons in there cannot see
anything until they sit on them until
they say
what the [ __ ] are they doing they
they're all like they're all being like
so like excited and
like nice to her now because they're
trying to get her to like choose
everything like
oh you know what else you can do not
pick me and we can be like best friends
oh my gosh it's such a good idea this is
so good that's today's best idea
that way you can escape all judgments
yeah is that what you guys want yeah
i trust your judgment are you guys sure
yes yeah yeah
all right okay should we close our eyes
destiny they're gonna vote you off if
you do it i know it's just like random
but i just like
it's still my finger pointing it's like
it means you got good odds of
staying in because they they like is
this random or are you
wait am i not you're choosing who you
want
[Applause]
please
you have to pay
[ __ ] the dude on the left here is gonna
get voted off because he hasn't like
really said anything to her yet
oh anyway that's right he doesn't even
care he's like yeah yeah but random
that's good yeah stay here
you pick one you pick someone you wanna
like
okay it's okay make it random can we
please make it random
please no you guys are kind of putting
like a lot of pressure on her like you
could just like
you could just go back to like writing
the names and do it anonymously like i
think that
this guy has worked with kids he know he
gets it they're working with kids right
now
exactly right guys
that's true okay we're going right i
didn't like that
all that for nothing eh you think they
voted off now because she didn't do it
yeah that'd be funny
destiny
the shock oh that's [ __ ] funny
yeah she didn't pick huh
who's the secret it's a secret hater i
love it the dude is like the most
shocked right now probably like oh
who would do that could you
she was the chosen one tracy
this guy on the left for sure voted
destiny you know it tracy
so there's two for tracy and two for
earl who voted for me
you want to know don't you it's killing
you isn't it
you just want to recoup though
right yeah yeah i think i think she's
the one that she has the weakest reasons
out of all of them right
i don't know the other girls trying to
sublease their apartment oh yeah that's
pretty [ __ ] too but
everyone loves her the most reason was
earl had something going on i don't
remember what it was
i don't remember either that must mean
it was bad so
you guys dislike you do you guys decide
which one of you leaves
you could just do a re-vote everybody
vote again but you can only vote on
tracy or earl
thank god this guy is here my [ __ ]
god how are they so incompetent
my god millennials it's a good thing he
got voted off first so he could like
just run the show yeah tell him how to
do it this one says
tracy okay that's fair
just gonna go who but who voted for me
oh no destiny that city looks like she's
gonna crack [ __ ]
i think destiny voted for destiny did
you vote for yourself
i actually did because i didn't yeah oh
my god
that's a smart move that's a big brain
move well done
that's genius she's she's been playing a
lot of among us she knows
she knows i just voted myself
then leave right if you don't think
you're gonna get the money you can just
leave if this was the last group that
had been like
girl excuse me we'll vote right now get
out of here
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh my god if destiny
wins that would make no sense then
right now she would be the she's playing
the ultimate playbook from what the
other girl did earlier about being like
talking about people voting for and
everything you know uh she's doing the
next level which is i voted for myself
because
you know i just feel so bad let's see if
it pays off what the balls he play
not to say that you you shouldn't get it
but if you're voting for yourself
yes it does kind of put into question
like do you really want it
oh [ __ ] i like this guy
doing it i guess well i also think that
like
good response good response you'd be a
politician right there
not anything against you but like you
and tracy were tied
so like i think that alone kind of
indicates who the top three
might be come back to me
okay we'll come back to the city oh yeah
oh i'm sorry no that's okay that's okay
he should have gone in for the attack
there yeah like no defense he's just
like
i like how let's go vocal earl i'm sorry
oh that sucks arrow no we're just
throwing the ball i'm not here
i smell the pot bro i'm about to be like
i need the money
so what is up with these people like
they're so timid on the couch and they
get kicked off they're like
yeah if those shoes bro i'm about to
murder them
yeah as soon as they're off it's like
yeah whatever i don't get i don't care
about the money anyway
what the [ __ ] is happening good fight
good job guys this is the final round
it's down to three people
all you guys have to decide on one
person that leaves with the thousand
dollars
i told my friends what i was going to do
here like i'll tell them i'm going to do
the charity and they're like you're
going to get
eliminated they said that
they said that i'm so tired of him
that's smart that's smart
because now they will feel bad if they
eliminate him right
yeah with this group i think so like
these guys are all in their feelings
very easily manipulated couldn't we like
um do you like split it 500 to charity
and then like 500
to like if like aliyah needs it that's
that's what i that's
what i was that's what i think yeah what
do you guys think i
i said destiny because that's the most
like that's like that surely can happen
like you can put the money into this
like right now it'll happen right now
charity like the money goes several
different places and healthcare that's
like such a big goal like all of those
are valid
but at this point and just like that's
the most practical thing as of right now
what okay let's let's reiterate this she
wants it for mental health reasons
and she says it costs 24 000 dollars
i think she's gonna pay her bill or
something like that i think she's
already had like the stuff going on
oh so she already has a bill of 24 grand
i think so i think that's how it went
i didn't get that i didn't get that at
all she played the mental health card so
i was like okay
you guys can't dispute me yeah i guess
you can't really critique that i mean i
don't know
middle one just wants to sublet her
[ __ ] flat that's it
that's such a bad reason she she got an
apartment she couldn't afford to begin
with
right and now she's trying to get out of
it and that's right
it's not i no
i think i wanted to give back to charity
that helped him i think that's nice
yeah and if you're well off already
there's never going to be a reason that
you need the money right
right there's never like uh
i think that's the we figured out the
showkin
can i kick off sonny a second time
because he was literally like i'm so
tired of hearing the word charity
he literally said i don't like him
yeah why does he hate charity so much
bro
like freaking leather jacket man came
off the couch and was just like
like ready to fight somebody oh my god
vote after second time a couch round i
like it
why do they hate charity so much the
fact that they voted out a dude who was
fundraising for kids whose parents have
cancer is sad
yeah i mean they were very quick on that
weren't they
yeah i mean that's like in line with
charity but now they're like making the
argument for i don't know
this is disappointing it really shows
the worst in the day i'm sick of hearing
about charity i didn't hear him say that
i didn't catch that
i don't care about charity you're so
wholesome when we first
i'd like to point out i'm not evil i'm
in a major we're literally
i like to point out i am a good person
i am going to school okay am an
intellectual
okay you see my glasses i mean i'm smart
what does it mean that you go to school
i literally had an interaction that when
i was playing games earlier i i told
this guy like bro just go outside and
he's like
i go outside i i have a i have a life i
go to college i'm like up
okay okay yeah what kind of argument is
that
i like i want to travel and live in the
communities that i'm planning to help
just because i said like i'm tired of
hearing charity doesn't mean that i
don't want to help people
i think i think it does bro i think it
does my dude
i'm sick and tired we're hearing about
these [ __ ] charities
i go to college i go to school [ __ ]
i'm a good person i am good
school everyone that goes to school is a
good person
you went to school i went to school at
one time
i don't go to school anymore
me neither one other thing is how is
still going to school even the flex like
you're literally still in school like
tell me about how you've graduated and
like
you know tell me how you actually
finished now then yeah exactly
i think we should split it 500 500 for
the thing but you're not allowed to do
that destiny
they said it in the beginning they're
all looking at this one chick like
they're about to just give her
all the money anyway like it hey i don't
know
i think so we have a person please say
they can't split it because that was a
good positive way
yeah and i wish the best of luck this
year since aliyah
what the [ __ ] the point was that you
couldn't do that stop it
[Applause]
oh look how happy they are look at the
wood
[Music]
oh they went with oh yeah
have we ever like finished one of these
episodes and been like oh that
seems like a good choice i'm happy with
that they never
do do you think the right person was
yeah yeah
congratulations everybody group hug
[Applause]
i hate this show i hate it so much why
did they treat the woman who just wants
to sublet the apartment that she choose
like the second coming of girl
yes yeah why did he do it she's the
chosen one
she's got the brightest clothes we gotta
she's the one
wait what arleigh i literally cheated
she didn't count full votes when sonic
got voted out that's so shitty what
really
when what did i miss we must investigate
oh here here why is someone talking
about the fact that i laid straight up
cheated
she only read five out of six votes last
one
[Music]
sunny one two three four five one two
three four five six
[Music]
and she won the money
ah what
[Music]
am i missing something here it's so
weirdly uh like it's a hate watch these
videos aren't they
it's such a weird watching
[Laughter]
she cheated
[Music]
what a title a lady cheats to win money
right oh thank you
there we go cheers well check out ken
and check out
the all the other videos we've done on
this and have a great
great one smash like if you're annoyed
because that helped the last video